[Music]
we go boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about how to
save the world
we have Katie Patrick joining us on the
show hello hello thank you so much for
coming on thanks for having me so
grateful I'm so I'm so happy that I
found you on the Internet
and that I found your work to be so
fascinating you agreed to come on the
show we're very excited to be talking to
you Katie Patrick's bio is very cool
katie is an Australian American
environmental engineering designer she's
the recent author of how to save the
world which applies powerful techniques
from the fields of data science game
design behavioral psychology and your
creative genius zone to make real and
measurable change on the causes you work
on and it's filled with awesome examples
it's also really measurable and
actionable on how to realize your full
idea potential into the world
Katie's links can be found below katie
patrick calm as well as her twitter so
go and take a look and let's start
things off with our fun question about
we find ourselves as stewards of earth
after this long period of evolution what
is your current take on the state of
humanity
well I'm super optimistic I'm a huge fan
of Steven Pinker's work and this recent
book called it's not actually that
recent called fact fulness which is
actually documenting how well we're
doing Humanity is getting better on
almost every single thing you can
measure now climate change is still very
scary and the extinction crisis is real
but there are many other things
basically almost just about anything
else that you can measure we're doing
better on so I see us kind of in this
adolescent stage and when I look about
where I see the future of humanity going
I don't see apocalypse and doom and
gloom
I see futuristic eco cities that are
covered with vegetation and human
humanity is realizing that their true
potential has been custodians of the
planet and I see so much good in people
I see people being incredibly creative
being compassionate being able to learn
incredibly complex and diverse skills
and I see this real hunger in people to
want to do something good with their
lives to be a good person and to
contribute something good and I can't
not see that when I look at humanity I
can't not see incredible things
happening so I get really sad when
people in my fellow scene of
environmental and social impact see this
really negative outlook because it's
just it's a lens that you can choose to
look at or if you can look at everything
that's bad or you can look at everything
that's good and I find everything that
is good far more compelling not just
because it's mayor an idea but because
the evidence backs it up as well I mean
you just look around at social and
environmental change community and the
innovation that's going on and you can't
not be inspired by what people are doing
so that's what I think that's that's my
take on where we're at the humanities
right now I think we're just blooming
and flowering in a whole lot of ways and
there are kinks along the road but don't
just look at the kinks look at how much
we're flowering yes yeah you very
clearly illustrate our slow but sure
update in our mental map and we're
slowly but surely moving towards this
more spiritually actualized planet this
cohesive unity and I love how you
illustrate
an environmental perspective we're
closer to Earth we're living maybe a
little bit more harmoniously with our
ecosystems and you have so many great
illustrations in your book that that
really illustrate this out for us and I
love them it's like our ecology which
we'll get to later the portmanteau of
architecture and ecology together so how
about you know who you are and how you
became who you are today 20 years of
environmental engineering and designing
work
how did Katy even pick up that interest
teach us about your journey well I I
think it was probably even more than 20
years I've always always loved the
environment always loved plants and
animals and even smooth my earliest
memories I was a child in the 80s even
when I would just see geology pictures
like illustrations in geology books of
the earth you know cut in half like a
you know you can see the magma inside I
just thought that was so cool I was like
wow look at the earth that's amazing and
there was a lot of that sort of
old-school environmental messaging that
Greenpeace activism style in the 80s and
I remember really paying attention to it
as a as a child and you know saved
whales save the Dolphins I wanted to
save the whales and save the Dolphins
and then as I got into my early teens
that was the kind of cook urbane kind of
grungy ninety kind of anti corporate
uprising Naomi Klein no logo kind of era
um I just went full-on into the the
whole activism thing like it just in
every way that I call it I completely
embodied it from there's about thirteen
or fourteen onwards and then went on to
study environmental engineering and then
made it my profession which brought me
into being a green building engineer and
corporate sustainability and then being
an entrepreneur and designer Silicon
Valley etc so it was just always there
and it's just so interesting you know I
mean part of what motivated me was
because I was distressed by what was
going on
deeply intensely distressed by what was
going on but then also even if you're
not distressed it's still probably that
I think the most interesting thing you
can do with your life like I mean even
as an engineer
as a computer programmer as a designer
as someone who has a technical craft
there's really nothing more exciting
than figuring out how do you build an
entire civilization that works in
synchronization with nature yes on every
level water carbon dioxide energy human
health yeah I mean it is a treasure
trove of interesting creative and
technical problems that I would like
Silicon Valley to get more interested in
get a bit out of the out of the little
app world yes look at the bigger picture
like how do you make a city work how do
you make an entire forest well had here
to keep the forests they're hard problem
to solve it's just so interesting and it
just gets more interesting yeah it's
it's so cool how you bring up that when
you're a little kid and you're first
seeing the the earth and the inside of
the earth the magma and getting excited
about that getting excited about all
these other little tiny bursts of
knowledge that got you interested in
environmental engineering all the way up
to now this bigger vision which we're
totally behind of getting Silicon Valley
out of the apps and into how do we NGO
engineer a more robustly connected
cybernetic earth system and we love that
notion and we're really happy that you
know that's why you're here talking to
us today about this big this big vision
how do we move the mentality towards the
bigger 8 billion humans on this rock in
synchrony with all of Mother Earth's
other plants animals geo geology all of
that stuff so that makes a lot of sense
because then that's the book how to save
the world and now let's let's let's talk
about this from from a perspective of
where you you and I we do things
similarly in some ways when we walk on
the street we see the current existing
infrastructure of the world and then we
see how it could be yeah and the
potential of what could be yeah in that
deep connected cybernetic earth
so tell us about how you both see that
and how you built that I built that
vision out and then also how you pick
which ideas you want to actually build
on I well you mentioned quite a few
things in in that um but first I think
we should explain what the cybernetic
earth is because not it's not a commonly
used phrase so what is so exciting about
environmental and social change right
now is that now that we have the
internet and we have a whole bunch of
computer frameworks that you can
download you can basically build just
about anything you want
through existing libraries of code there
are also low-cost sensors that are being
you can go to sparkfun comm you can just
go on Amazon or Ebay
and you can get a Raspberry Pi Arduino
and you can make with not terribly
advanced skills just through YouTube
tutorials you can make whatever you want
that can actually sense sense anything
about the planet you can sense pressure
how heavy something is you can sense if
something's moving you can sense air
pollution you can sense light you can
sense temperature and you can do it all
DIY of stuff that you can buy and figure
out yourself so and there are startups
working in just about every space with
this so the earth has been covered with
sensors it's becoming like digital eyes
and ears for seeing the planet so things
that we couldn't see before like we
couldn't like we don't know what the air
pollution is in this room or out on the
street right we don't know what the
surface temperature is of a particular
hot surface in summer in a city that's
that's baking and making people use more
air conditioning this would probably be
a good time to even bring up some of the
designs and concepts that you have on
your website katie patrick comm ford
slash designs you talked about the
cybernetic earth and all of these
incredible sensors that we can have
these new digital eyes and ears here
here you have urban canopy thermal
taking high-resolution thermal images of
cities in the summer to show urban heat
island effect and then you can rank
properties based on heat scores then you
have Boston's green cover is 27% learn
how to green your city urban canopy it's
very interesting as well if Seattle
Boston San Jose how they're competing in
terms of their green cover over time and
and that's enabled again by the low cost
satellites that are there I mean once
upon a time we couldn't have the
abundance of satellite imagery that we
have now and now it's really easy to get
partly because of this electronic sensor
explosion that's what's happening now
people talk about Internet of Things but
really when I think the Internet of the
the earth or earth things and that is
just as an entrepreneur as a technical
person who likes to come up with ideas
which I know probably your audience and
the Silicon Valley community are I mean
this is the treasure trove of exciting
potential and so I come up with ideas
and I'm mock-up the ideas I design them
and I put them on my website it would be
great if each one was a startup but I
have more ideas I have ideas constantly
well I can't come up with startups
constantly so I just designed them and
sort of put them out into the swells can
pick them up and execute them if they
really enjoy the idea they can they're
welcome to steel them but I would prefer
to work with someone into I do I don't
believe that I own ideas or anyone
really owns them they do they just sort
of part of the ether and they're
channeled through years but if somebody
does want to steal the idea I would like
it if they would get in contact with me
and maybe work we could work together on
the on the idea but it's just this is
enabling a whole new different type of
environmental activism that we didn't
have available to us before because when
you can see the numbers it's a little
bit like a I'm like a Fitbit watch that
you might wear or even getting on the
scales and seeing how much you weigh or
seeing nutritional labeling that's
another example of just being able to
see the numbers or a Prius with the
dashboard showing that we're getting
those feedback loops of data and then we
can do comparisons you can be like oh
that's what that many calories that has
200 calories that has 400 calories so
I'll choose 200 if I'm on a diet and 400
if I'm like really hungry right numbers
enable us to make good decisions and
we're highly reactive we're highly
emotionally reactive to numbers and so
once we have all this data we have all
those numbers it enables us to be able
to use all these mechanisms of change
that we didn't have before before it was
just like we're freaking out because
everything's dying so we have to like
have a protest or like get really upset
about it all make it
cumin tree it was that was more of the
sort of like phase phase one of
environmental change
I'd like sustainability 1.0 so this
sustainability 2.0 earth is data-driven
behavior change type of Fitbit for the
planet type of for the planet I love how
you also explain that it's the Internet
of Things with especially the 5g
infrastructure that's coming in and
abling us to get all this data and then
processing the data making sense of it
but also this component of of things
like augmented reality and the potential
that that has to give us immediate
insights into our environments and make
smarter decisions that way all of these
technologies coming together good I was
just about to go but we just wanted to
interrupt you in case you were going to
say something else this is the Civic orb
I want to show this one I know but this
one's so interesting because an
electronic public installation light
that shows the electricity use of an
entire city in real time communicated by
the color of the glowing orb so here you
can see in San Francisco you're using
sixty four point seven megawatt that's a
correct number by the way
correct yeah it's probably but it's blue
to red as your scale of load high an
energy leaderboard for apartments a
green cocoon for the vehicles this is
very beautifully designed you know we
love stuff like this and then Garden
City augmented reality the Garden City
app used augmented reality to allow
users to superimpose their ideas for
living walls urban trees and green roofs
on the urban services around them so
then this is kind of like what could
potentially be with augmented reality
yeah and I got the idea from that
because I stumbled on this way of
thinking I actually drew from the
self-help movement I was reading some
health some self-help book could you
know they're all about like make a mood
board about the life you want you know I
make a vision board that imagine your
vision and it all
it will kind of happen and that's why I
started thinking about and I realized
that oh I actually kind of already do
this for the urban landscape I kind of
imagined buildings what they would look
like if they were covered in moss and
green and trees and these kind of
futuristic cities and so I started doing
this as a practice actually imagining
the future world that I would want to
have if I could imagine I can imagine
the utopian version of my own life but
what if I imagine the utopian version of
the whole earth and so the limitation of
the self-help movement and a lot of
spirituality too is that it's kind of
all about the self it's always very
self-focused for what if we take those
things that we can learn from that and
we think well what about the whole world
right and so they've become really
fascinating for me for seeing how you
would need a vision and then I realized
that that was inherent to the creative
process because if an architect wants to
build a building right they need to they
made a comment or model this is just the
scientific study of creativity right if
you want to make a dress so you want to
make a gown even if you wanna build
software you imagine it you create this
thing and it's called the positive
constructive imagination that's what
Sciences scientists who study this call
it you can positively construct in your
imagination a detailed thing right and
then you go through the process of
reverse engineering that and then you
make it so you're imagining and you're
making and you're imagining and you're
making and that's what creativity is
right so in order to do that you need to
have the vision you need to have the
dream and that's why the Martin Luther
King's Speech was so popular because it
used this I have a dream and you didn't
say everything is really bad all the
time this is really terrible there's a
bit of that in the speech but it's
creating a landscape of where you want
to go and that is incredibly powerfully
motivating to people so if we want to
have cities become green covered with
trees and vegetation which I think they
need to be they for engineering reasons
for thermal companies for water for
health it's it's engineering you just
cannot build a city completely out of
concrete and bitumen and have it totally
work right you need a lot of green space
right way more than we have now force
therapy is a very real thing decreasing
with us all levels from our connection
to guide everything
yeah study off to study about it so the
first thing we need is this a augmented
reality app where you can make imaginary
green cities with AI that's right
because it helps really with people that
are going and and envisioning what the
future could be like of the cities and
that's and that's the idea is that when
you can see it you can be it and you can
set these action steps to get to that to
that point and that's why you also have
so many of the beautiful illustrations
in the book of what it looks like to
have greener cities more ecologically
harmonious places for us to to live yeah
and the long explanation is because
there's a substantial theoretical basis
for that it's not just like oh I'm gonna
do something with a are you don't it be
cool to like put trees and things in a
are it comes from a much more
substantial theoretical basis of why we
need to see images of what we want to
have in order to do the work to make
that come true it's an essential part
but I think is is not missing but the
volume is turned way down on those
visions of what we want and I don't
think we should turn the volume way up
way up so that's that that's that idea
way up I'm so so so agree with you and
we're gonna turn that volume way up
together and through disseminating memes
that inspire people to to get used to
get building the future that they want
to see especially on an environmental
engineering level I love that so much
this is a couple of the other quick ones
on the way a public energy displays for
commercial buildings big air quality
displays also very interesting
small public air quality screens a car
is one of my favorites a carbon powder
global carbon dioxide imagine a little
parts-per-million happy in in Times
Square
right a little parts per million and in
maybe in in in in other cities around
the world maybe in every city maybe
right maybe another city that has a
decent of me you know how many parts per
million carbon dioxide are in the air
right now ahead do you know it's almost
it's almost 400 well we've got a thing
right here that says it so that's your
but most people don't know even people
that work on environmental issues often
unless you just work specifically on
climate change a lot of people don't
know what that number is so then just
knowing the number is very motivating
numbers important but also knowing that
what has it been it has increased from
300 parts per million to 400 parts per
million in what the last like 20 years
or exactly I think in the last I think
it was 280 parts per million at the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
oh so that's actually a hundred 50 years
yeah that's a long time ago okay okay so
the theme about a hundred years let's
say it's been going up quite a bit
interesting so things like this they
give us a visual status a health bar of
the earth I like that a lot and and it
keeps people engaged with with what
what's going on on the planet another
one is this V score plant-based swaps
that restaurants can make to help people
eat more plants and less animals this is
very very cool as well all you need is
sometimes is that little nudge you you
make this so clear in the book as well
if you just you know change up some of
the words you use or if you change up
some of the messaging around or
incentive systems you can get people to
make healthier more sustainable
decisions yeah it's actually there's a
lot of tools you can use what I mean
tools I just mean like the way you would
something like there's a lot of study
that's been done on these things called
social norms which not everyone has
heard about
social norms basically mean like kind of
what everybody else is doing like so you
could say there's a whole bunch of
basically ways to access the
motivational core of the human mind so
if you want to get people to eat less
meat and more plants you could you know
shame them or fear them you Meat Is
Murder meat is terrible you're a bad
person if you eat meat so that kind of
causes people to shut down another way
using social norms as you would use a
phrase that says more and more people
are going vegan now everybody's going
vegan vegan is the most popular thing to
do do you know yeah eight out of ten
people are eating more plant-based foods
you basically say look at what everyone
else is doing and because we're
inherently social animals we want to be
doing what everyone else is doing and we
want to be doing well also in comparison
so then if you can take numbers and also
rank people to be like you're like in
you know the sort of like bottom 20th
percentile you know you could do better
there's room for improvement and you've
actually got a barometer you put a
number it's not a binary on or off like
vegan or not vegan or good or bad or eco
certified or not eco certified you've
actually got this number that you can
work with and you can iteratively
improve it so you for that feedback of
iteration so that the V score is the the
percentage is the ratio of calories of
animal calories to plant calories so you
just put a number and it's just science
it's not like there's the plant calories
yeah yeah very so if you're either if
you're 95 percent of a school 95 percent
calories from plants that's pretty good
right you just have to take something
like your purchase data and then being
able to run that through an algorithm
that's able to say ok you ate a burger
that had this much animal cat caloric
content for you ate a salad that's had
this much of a veteran vegetable caloric
content so this is potentially through
purchase data and through algorithms can
parse that so we don't have to manually
go and log every single thing that
we eat but this is like kind of like you
were saying a little bit of the Jones
back to or where you see like we you
right we are social animals that like to
see where you know well are you you know
Katie's ranking in the top 10 percentile
on on plant-based nutrition I mean what
do I need to do to get in the top 10%
that's fine and if it's really low
you're just like gee well you know it
doesn't need to be I went vegan I didn't
go vegan if you could go from a 20% in
face for up to a 50% that would be a
huge improvement you know anyone I feel
feel good about that so these kind of
mechanisms of using measurement using
comparison using positive feedback like
hey you went up by 10% good job and
social norms saying everyone else is
doing it like for example if you are a
sustainability manager in a city and you
might have like a $500,000 budget to
spend on a marketing campaign to get
someone to do something you could do it
really wrong you could do it all the bad
way you could use the wrong phrasing the
wrong type of images not use any of the
techniques that work you spend the money
and nothing happens and this has
happened over and over again I speak to
people all the time
and they're like we tried something like
that they didn't work and I said well I
believe your design I'm like Willie when
you actually test this through the
academic method if you were to have
phrased it differently you may very well
have had a triple fold a change so
everywhere people are making these
mistakes you make so many good ones so
many mistakes but I just say over again
it that it's just fascinating by just
changing a few words that's not even
like building an app not even writing a
line of code yeah words so the book has
like a nice little snapshot of it the
field of behavioral psychology is much
bigger than what's there but it's a
great starting point where I put a bunch
of studies in you know like another one
it's like is money and motivator when it
was tested if you tell someone if you
and it's actually two studies about this
about one is driving the Prius and the
other one is saving energy in your home
it was found that the message about
carbon dioxide like you'll save this
much carbon dioxide worked better than
the money won and everyone thinks it's
the money won right but the carbon
dioxide is actually more of a
it's not that much money that you save
and we're just a little bit more
emotionally connected to all here to
polar bears than all true sense you know
yeah there's I want to also speak about
this from not only a you know behavioral
psychology perspective which you know
you give so many good examples of here
but also I want to talk about it from
moving people from an old mental map to
a new mental map this is something that
we also vibe on on a deep level we think
about it as one of the greatest games
that we can play is figuring out how to
update civilizations code how to
maximize our own potential bring our
ideas into the world and so when you
think about seed of a child getting the
right nutrients getting access to the
right creative tools and being able to
express themselves fully into the world
we want to see how we can maximize the
potential of every single seed to update
civilizations code and be in that have
that have that be a co-creative process
so I want to ask you about you know your
vision with moving people from an old
mental map to a new mental map in the
most effective strategies in doing that
process well I'm not sure if I know that
much about the most effective strategy
tools are basically that ah I think yeah
well I I mean for the the the big kind
of upgrade of the mental map um I do
think I made the decision a few years
ago to delve into what I call the
creative genius or you know which I'm so
compelled by I even put a chapter in it
right up the front of the book and I
think everything good that comes out of
life maybe everything's a bit of a
stretch but a lot of good things well
the core of who you are is making
getting your creative genius thrown out
of you and cultivating it and practicing
it almost like an Olympic athlete
practices their sport right or a pianist
practices the piano like a professional
pianist right that you make that
whatever your unity
gift is you make it the Sun in your life
and the other things in your life like
you you know exercise money family
friends even children are the kind of
planets that go around the central Sun
and that Sun kind of warms it's where
the energy comes from for the other
planets or if the orbiting bodies to get
life from and that's kind of my overall
kind of world view of how to go about
how to go about life and how to go about
your own social and environmental impact
so I think where that comes in to this
whole idea of upgrading you know
humanity is a mental map it's time to
move away from this worldview of that
you need to have certain types of what
do they call it like the linear career
you know you have like college then you
get the mortgage then you get the
husband or the wife and the children and
then you get work work work and then you
get the reach like a million dollars
worth of funds under management or
whatever and then maybe you know people
oh you do your MBA before you turn 30
before you have your first baby which is
actually what someone exactly wrote on a
forum once I was like who is this lady
it was like Rachel that she had and was
married for exactly five years before
she got pregnant and I'm like okay I
like that alright there we do is kind of
like life goals that we get raised with
the expectation of having but if you do
that in a way not that any of those
things are bad to have but if you do
that without making your creative genius
so in the center of your sort of your
life then you people end up getting
corroded you know the marriage falls
apart you know they end up getting
really depressed with their job they're
like well I'm a corporate lawyer and I
own $300,000 a year but I'm totally
suicidal and there's kind of this
existential angst that we have and this
craving for meaning and purpose I
believe is because we're not making that
the center of our life and you may need
to trade off some material wealth in
order to cultivate that you probably do
but what you end up with a different
sort of capital you end up with social
capital that you know for example you
have like a following like I've got this
wonderful following on on Twitter and
Facebook that a love my work and a
really encouraging and that's a real joy
to have
I have an enormous amount of creative
capital social capital lots of friends I
get invited to be a part of stuff and
intellectual capital and what I've built
in my work so you kind of build when you
invest in a creative genius on you
builds like an internal garden like it's
like watering your own internal
spiritual garden and where this all
intersects with saving the world is that
I don't think there's any difference
between watering this internal garden
and saving the world I think it's the
same thing I think when you invest in
your creative genius when you water that
that thing that you love to do that
thing that you love to contribute you
end up contributing it to the world and
it ends up being that the gift to the
world that's what you contribute this
book is me investing in my creative
genius so no this book is a gift to the
world the world can now have it right
it's not just in my head anymore like it
used to be like it used to be and it
took that that commitment and it's just
so rewarding so I think we need to go
through life and we need to raise the
next generation of children with that
worldview yes yes but if not just but
not just about the I mean the gift
that's something that people bring up a
lot like Oprah is like your unique
creative fingerprint whatever it's also
matching it with contribution that's one
thing that I think doesn't always get
talked about as much everybody likes to
think of themselves as they're your the
the unique creative flower underneath we
all are though but what how are you
gonna contribute it to the world correct
what's the point of having a creative
genius on if it's trapped in your
Dropbox folder and it's stuck in the
drawer and it's in your garden so nobody
can see it you want to contribute it you
want to share it with the most people as
possible so you have this you have the
creative garden you're your creative
genius onus is on your planet you're
your celestial body and then you're
contributing the energy of the star it's
radiating out the garden is Hat reaping
is having fruits emerge from it that
then you can then go and distribute so
it's kind of like the sun's energy is
distributed to his planet or the gardens
are being distributed towards other
people in the community so I like this a
lot is he has to happen it's not gonna
be stuck in your yeah
yeah but it takes practice like I wake
up every morning and my first thing and
I've been doing this for about three
years now
is my first thing is today I will devote
the next three hours so some time this
is before the baby gets up it's like
5:00 in the morning sometimes it's after
she's at school but my first priority is
how do I do the most creative thing I
can do one second thing that is the most
benefit to the world so it's about my
credit unions own that's also about the
contribution it's not in a vacuum in
this and then I just like I'm like
universe tell me tell me what is it and
sometimes it's like I gotta get you
booked out you got to finish it and
sometimes it's like you've got to
interview that person on a podcast like
that's what the universe is calling you
to do we've got to make a design of a
giant co2 counter that's going to be in
every city in the world
that's good and it's not gonna happen
overnight a lot of millennial jennszoo
immediate gratification systems are
saying that the though the fruits from
the garden are going to come in a day
that you know you know and they're gonna
be distributed in a day this takes a
long time to write something like how to
save the world and to get it you know to
take everything from your mental lattice
in your mind and be able to distribute
that in the most compression algorithm
way that inspires as many people around
the world as possible is it takes time
and it's hard work and so it's important
to be patient but I love your analogies
here they're so so good the and the way
that these things tied together is that
every single person's creative genius
zone is encoded in their seed and then
it's up to us to give the right tools
and potential for them to discover that
and then enable the the that to be
catalyzed into everyone else's worldview
is what their their their contribution
is and so I love this tying this tying
thread between
but of just how beautiful is it to think
about it as a planet and as a star and
planets or as a garden and the fruits
from the garden I love that so much
yeah I've been doing it for a few years
now even though I did environmental work
before then I didn't sort of do it with
this way sometimes I just lie in my bed
and I was at my inner garden it feels so
full I think I have this beautiful child
and I I almost feel it like in my body
you know I like it sort of feels so
fertile and I feel so appreciative that
I am that I've been able to put in the
time and that I actually just did it
that I just committed to to doing these
you know sometimes it's an hour
sometimes it's three hours sometimes
it's more and just the extreme
ruthlessness of putting in that time and
I like you said it is it is I think it's
difficult to do anything good there is a
lot of this and you know people trying
to sell you on courses like oh I made
like fifty thousand dollars on the
internet or like I went to Silicon
Valley and then the people that make a
lot of money in Silicon Valley they go
they just like build a company and sold
it for twenty or fifty million dollars
but I think behind anything that's
genuinely good like a good film a good
book
good startup not one of those like ones
that just sort of starts and then dies
but genuinely really substantial
startups there's a hugely long period of
devoted craftsmanship that's gone into
it and what I sort of love about
pursuing the creative genius or the son
idea of your life is that it's not
promising new fame and fortune it's only
promising creative fulfillment right the
promise of pursuing it crave genius own
is only gonna promise that you'll get
more in your creative genius zone and at
that garden that you know garden will be
enough you may make a million dollars
you may not you may go for fifteen years
without you know earning five or ten
thousand dollars a year um you may get
even get depressed and come out of it
it's not promising all there's kind of
other promises you know if you go to
Harvard
then you know your life will be amazing
because you went to Harvard but
apparently your students at Harvard are
more depressed than anybody else
much pressure on them right to perform
but it almost like eclipses all of those
other kind of things that society is
telling you to achieve yeah yeah without
over-promising what its gonna give you
and I just find personally that that's
enough that's enough for me the
fulfillment of the creative genius zone
and the impact that that has we
sometimes we talk about as different
colors on the color wheel that there's
orange on the color wheel let's say
impacts just your family and you're just
let's say just your family and then
Green impacts your family and your
friends and then blue maybe impacts the
community as well and then red on the
color wheel maybe impacts the whole
world with one of the ideas and so these
are colors on the color wheel not that
one is better or worse than others it's
just that the the creative genius zone
that you end up exploring and fulfilling
with your life is going to have
different scales of impact as well as
different financial levels of success
there's these types of things but really
it's about the waking up in the morning
and feeling like you're radiating with
love and passion for what your adventure
is that day yeah although I wouldn't
necessarily oversell it that it's often
not like that it's like but you're in
the in the game I mean what I talk about
in the book because I couldn't I didn't
feel like I couldn't write a book
although the we haven't gone that much
into the sort of technical part of the
world we're about to without touching on
this is that like happiness isn't this
plet or that you reach in life it's not
like you're just like do a few things
and then you're like oh I got it I got
the job I got the money
I got the partner the house now
happiness achieves like go me um it's
more of this this cycle of the hero's
journey where you take on a new
challenge and I mean this is why we love
movies where people go through
challenges imagine you watch a movie in
someone's just like happy all the time
right oh my life's great and then like
at the end of the review well I feel
great it's this thing about you take on
something new you take on a new
challenge and the challenge is full of
difficulty and then you take it on and
you figure it out and you go
it's called the inmost cave in the
journey we right up against your
greatest existential angst like the the
hardest thing in the world your greatest
fears the hardest thing and then you
kind of find this otherworldly strength
and then you break through right and if
you're taking on something hard like a
startup or a book or whatever you're
going through that all the time you're
up against and the thing is and then you
sort of come at the other side and then
you reap the rewards so happiness
researchers happiness is more like I see
like a fruit that you pick up along the
journey you're like you go through the
hard-bitten then you're like Oh
strawberries and then it starts again
the cycle and then you know and then
you're in the kind of cauldron at the
coalface of that hard thing of pushing
yourself and then the nice things more
diversity and than a mango more
adversity I think when you see life and
that's what it but that's what it's
meant that's what life is meant to be
yes like we are built for this we are
built to go into the challenge yes and
then reap the rewards of the challenge
yes so now that I see the world like
this that it's all this thing you go
into and then you sort of have a nice
time then you go and you come out of a
nice time you have a very different
expectation of life then that all you
just kind of like reach this plateau
where everything's going to be cool
because that just doesn't happen maybe
it happens for some this is actually a
perfect way to describe how we both also
I'm pretty sure you also think similarly
about levelling up a character in a game
and so when we're you know the character
doesn't reach level 10 or 20 or whatever
and then it's like oh all said and done
it's this constant process of you're at
level one you're getting through
adversities building up skills getting
some rewards experience points level up
you're at level two now and then you do
the same process and you keep going
leveling up till all the way until
you're you've achieved all of these
awesome fulfilling fulfilling drives
that you've that you've set forth in
your life and
ok let's get into some of the technicals
now okay let's do this so I keep going
on about this stuff forever I don't and
I love I love hearing you talk about it
because you have really synthesized a
lot of the core concepts together and
it's it's very powerful but also I mean
you can't get serious about changing the
world unless you get serious about your
own existential needs and your own
creative drive like they're all into
woven the reason why you want to change
the world where you want to have an
impact on the world is because of your
spiritual existential yearning to do
that and you can't do it without the
creative genius own so understanding
that you're not kind of just like oh I'm
gonna start a hydroponics company and
I'm just gonna like share vegetables
with everybody and then you're gonna
just experience this wonderful perfect
life I mean I can't write a book about
saving the world unless I get really
real with that process that you have to
go into this difficulty of pushing
yourself and then come out again and go
into it with that expectation so I
thought it was very important to get
that real that human personal journey
side in in the book because the the way
I wrap up the book at the end is saying
that everybody has lots of ideas right
but you need to be able to take the leap
you need to actually pick up the phone
cut the call and call up the government
for the idea you have you have to pitch
for funding you have to be every day in
the game right and that's where people
hold back people want to do the thing
but they don't make the phone call they
don't pitch they don't spend the weekend
on YouTube figuring out how to solve the
electronics right yeah unless you get
really real with your own personal
energy with how you're going about
whatever project you're working on
you're not going to be able to do it for
the years and actually make the social
impact that you want to have you really
have to have the fire inside you to do
it otherwise you just another person has
got ideas it's just like well I'd really
like to make the world a better place
you know that'd be so cool like the
execution is so crucial in the seedy
reality that we live in let's let's get
into some of the technicals so I want
you to teach us about this idea
of you know setting a goal in a basic
unit of measure and then there's this
process of a value action gap with
behavior design and we have one of the
you know we have your your really cool
rainbow this how to save the world
rainbow caterpillar in summary that's it
towards the end of the book where you
actually lay out the ten critical
components that you actually go through
throughout the book and so we'll go
through some of these things as as we
talk but go ahead and explain to us on
that first part of you know setting a
goal and this basic unit of measure is
is just such a you know a very simple
thing but we don't sometimes you know
think about the importance of that yeah
sorry the value action gap is this
phenomenon which very few people know
about but everybody who wants to make an
impact on the world really must know
about it and it's very easy to test and
it's just this if you have a class of
twenty people and you show them a
documentary about climate change and
energy they will become one educated
about the topic and two they will care
you can test them test them beforehand
just them afterwards you test them six
months later it's whether they did
anything they create an action nothing
you can ask people do you care about the
environment eighty five ninety cent of
people will say answer eight percent
will say sure they would you spend more
money on products sure when they're at
the shop no all right so the word value
action gap means that people have the
values right you can educate people and
you can make them genuinely care but
that doesn't lead to a behavior because
trying to get people to do a behavior in
the physical world is kind of a
different science to getting people to
be educated and care you can give people
so it's whether you're taking and it's
also called the information deficit
hypothesis which means
basically if you think that you can get
people to change by giving them
information glaciers are falling apart
animals are getting extinct trees are
being cut down this is all the well the
state of water quality is in lakes right
giving people information which is
documentaries books blogs podcasts even
games educational games fall into this
anything that's educational or
content-based right it'll work to
educate people but it won't work to get
people to change or it might have tiny
bit the behavioral lens is a totally
different path to go down if you
actually want to get people to act and
you don't even need to educate people
that much you can just do a five percent
of the education you're planning
planning on doing so the way this goes
into measurement is the first thing you
need to do is to just have a look at the
data have a look at the numbers now this
might sound incredibly obvious oh yeah
look at the numbers of what you want to
change but I've been speaking to social
and environmental entrepreneurs impact
people my whole life and I would say at
least five maybe even eight out of ten
people when you ask them about the
numbers they don't know or they haven't
even looked at it people work on climate
change without knowing the carbon
intensity or the kilowatt hours in their
own city like they just haven't looked
it up right yeah they'll be working on
all different sorts of projects people
work on food waste without actually
looking at the data on food waste people
working on promoting veganism and
vegetarianism without looking at the
numbers of how much meat is actually
produced where are the abbatoirs
how does it work where as it gets old
you know actually looking at like a data
stream of meat and animal products
rather than a vegan community that we
want to make bigger right so number one
is just looking at the numbers that's
the first step just look at the numbers
and you will find that there's actually
a really interesting body of of research
and it's called disclosure or
transparency which is where the
government mandates that the numbers
have to be transparent so it's what we
have with nutritional labeling you if
you sell food you have to put
nutritional labels on it and the
government makes you do that and it has
a design parameter so if the government
makes the data makes all the companies
make the data public it's the same with
Car Safety Ratings
right as well then the numbers are all
public and then once the numbers of
public then you've really got something
to work with to try and drive change so
it's just this one like basic thing and
this is quite in the book from Bill
Gates who says that you know the first
thing you need to do to make change I
can't read exactly is to measure
everything and figure out a measure to
drive change and a feedback loop and he
says it sounds really simple but it's
surprising how hard it is to do and how
easy it is to get wrong or how easy it
is to be forgotten yes so I think maybe
half to three quarters of people working
in this space just don't do the
measurement side very well or haven't
made it the core of their model and
that's the first thing just make sure
what you're doing is making an impact
make sure you're looking at the numbers
and so all the other nine steps in the
book build from that one basic
measurement and the idea of making that
a feedback loop like a Fitbit so when
you make something you basically all
look what we did worked we could measure
it we reduce plastic by 10 percent again
it sounds so simple that you'd be
surprised how often it is not done yeah
and this is one of those one of those
concepts of such importance because we
you know you give this great example
you're in the classroom and you're
giving people powerful education on a
subject and they're like yay we tested
that we understood and we incorporated
this into our lives and people say that
they would you go and make an actionable
change but then when they're actually
there months later they're potentially
not making actionable change so how do
we get people to make an actionable
change well data is a major part of this
that displays these visuals that you're
explaining to giving me giving us
totally change B behavior when you're
seeing the parts-per-million here or
you're seeing beautiful augmented
reality displays of the trees on top of
buildings where you go as you walk down
Market Street in San Francisco or
through Central Park in New York
wherever you're at that it totally makes
sense that these are the ways to
incrementally get people to to desire to
actually make
with their behavior as well and now I
want you to give us a kind of like one
of your main principles of design with
changing behavior well there's there's
three that go together that I think are
the most simplest framework for what
excite that's in the book but also is
personally most interesting to me which
is one you measure everything and make a
feedback loop so a good example of that
is getting people to slow down driving
right so you have like billboards or
maybe TV commercials about in Australia
we used to have these horrific lis
frightening television commercials
telling people to stop speeding I was
screaming blood you know very scary but
then that's not someone's when they're
watching that they're not in the car
right there
kind of watching television and they may
be in the car like 24 hours later rent
versus so that's an educational approach
right so the data-driven approach would
be those signs that show you how fast
you're going and they say maybe flash
saying how many miles you're going so if
you're coming up to a school zone you
know they'll say this is the speed limit
this is how many miles you're going
instant change data feedback loop got
you straight away that's an example of
changing behavior so the the educational
approach just doesn't quite filter down
into the behavior the numbers and so
there are a number of examples in the
book of showing people whether it's how
much energy you using paper recycled at
universities cans recycled you just show
people a number and you can even do it
by hand you're going to be electronic
you can just write it with a pen
obviously you need somebody updating it
a sign that shows how many cans have
been recycled the number of cans
recycled went up by like sixty something
percent I mean it's a big changes like
sixty
I think it's 67 or 68 percent similar
with paper I think it was 77 percent
energy showing people how much energy
they use it can be between 5 or 7
percent even some case studies go up to
40 percent just showing people the
numbers in a feedback loop right anyway
so that's like the first principle the
second principle is social comparison
like what we were talking about
why when like if you were like if we got
a little report card that said oh you
use you know or you create five pounds
of trash and I create seven pounds I
don't feel like oh why am I am i doing
more this is I got to get it down I
could beat him I could at least not be
worse
so this social comparison based on data
again it segues from data it's quite
possibly one of the most powerful ways
to get into the human psyche so we could
both watch a documentary on garbage and
be like oh that's bad right but if we're
given the data and then we're ranked and
compared and maybe there's all of us in
a classroom or in a community or a
university or in an office and we're all
ranked in a leaderboard from top to
bottom yeah
then we're all like I want to do better
on the leaderboard you know not because
we're all desperately competitive but we
all just sort of want to do better right
it's just this disclosure of data so
that social comparison is the second one
and the third one is color right people
that are doing not as well can get red
or corporations or block city blocks or
governments anyone anything a product
and you've got the whole rainbow to work
with Green is good all the way down and
these basically three you gave this
example with your car color stickers oh
yeah that's a low-tech thing right we
already have miles per gallon disclosure
labeling for cars but they don't include
color and what's very interesting about
color is it is immediately recognizable
by the human mind like that's why
traffic light colors right can you
imagine if the traffic light said the
words go and stop like it actually said
stop and go in words without the color
like how much harder it would be to
figure out what was going it'll just
take you a little while right whereas
the color is it's just so so immediate
and it's also emotional if you get red
you like if you see a red light flashing
you mean something like oh that's bad
right we're green light flashing you're
like okay we're cool so colors enormous
ly motivating and is signaling
it's signals data you can put those
three things together and those
basically three principles in my design
page on my website is the basic
framework for all of my concept designs
and it's something anybody can bring in
to their project and you can apply it to
just about just about anything and then
you can just add more bells and whistles
on the top right but I mean that's just
like some just super powerful mechanisms
and you'll come across organizations
that don't have that right so for
example environmental certifications
that are just like one or they have it
relator and have it you know even like
be caught for example they don't have
that disclosure of data the feedback
loop the comparisons the leaderboard
based on data and then applying color
and range these basic principles until
you really wonder like what's the link
of causality maybe it is making a big
change but I don't know if the causality
is really very substantial
these are so so good I love color I love
the the data being more transparent and
more and more visible at moving forward
to actionable change I love this step of
measuring it the goal visualizing the
new world having your idea storm at the
evaluation behavioral change systems
thinking game design telling the story
tribes and tipping points technology
this is kind of your curve and I want to
say let's put it back ok right my
caterpillar even though I made it the
goal visualize your world idea storm
idea valuation behavior change systems
thinking game design tell your story
tribes and tipping points and technology
and so we kind of spent a good amount of
time already getting up through behavior
change so now let's talk about this
latter half the blue to purple so teach
us about getting us all the way up to
tribes tipping points and Technology in
terms of saving the world ok ok the book
is very I actually have a two hour
workshop on this it takes me two hours
to go through all the case studies as
quickly as possible so it's a it's some
ambitious to try and get it all in to
the interview so basically it yet so
step two sorry I've just got a slightly
start at the beginning a bit further
back but don't you have a goal so you do
where you're at you're where you are now
and then you say where you want to go
right goal a measurable goal might sound
really obvious again it's missing from
so many organizations but once you put a
goal a goal number you can visualize it
if your goal is to cover cities with 80%
vegetation then you can visualize you
see so having you a numerical goal like
a progress bar this is where you are now
this is your progress by where you want
to go that's a design feature and then
track it along the way and then
visualize the code talks of it visualize
this world and make that your big dream
that you are selling and then from there
you can extract ideas once you've got
this visualization it's one of the
exercises right a hundred ideas down
just keep digging and digging and
digging into the ideas and then you and
you've got your ideas then you can
figure out how to assess them and then
layo these things like social norms
pledges just asking somebody to write
down instead of making an elaborate
documentary about some issue just go up
to people and say would you like to
write down something that you would like
to commit to like what's something you
would like to do better in terms of an
environment just name something
transition to biodegradable yeah so if I
got you to write down with a with a pen
like you got a pen right there yes if
you just write a little norwich and
you're right I pledge to Katie to
transition - you don't have to put my
name down I placed a transition to
biodegradable yes yes okay that one
behavior totally low-tech no budget is
one of the most powerful things you can
do to get people to change and you can
add that pledge on to anything you're
trying to get people to do because it's
free right it's easy you have an art
project have the people look at the art
project and then pledge you've got
someone standing there with like a you
know so easy but it will work that will
work where it's just getting them to
learn about it won't come work so that's
the example of in and behavior um
systems thinking it's just like you know
something for example like defaults like
one example is with organ um like
America has a lower rate of organ
donation on the driver's license than
other countries because other countries
have a default you have to opt out
versus opt in so it's just a form design
thing like it's either crossed out and
you have to ticket or if you just do
nothing you're instantly in social
example with air aircraft meals what if
all the meals would default vegan and
then you have to opt in to get meat most
people would just go with the vegan and
so you could take all of that
environmentally heavy meat dishes out of
the out of the aircraft and you wouldn't
be telling you see whether you can still
have meat we're not forcing
vegetarianism by anybody but it's just
looking for those default cases where we
do things just because it's the default
mm-hmm is the only are you putting
plastic water out for everybody where
everyone just grabs it just because it's
the default yeah you know all these
little things looking through um and now
the game design is looking at ways that
you can what you can do with your data
so we've already talked about comparison
progress bars like there's an example of
like emotive animals that if you just
put
it's a positive feedback so you say good
job right and then the animal is smiling
that these the students that were tested
on how much they how well they did on
the test did 23% better than what using
an owl that was no expression so al with
no expression you put a smiley face on
the owl their scores go up by 23% okay
these are just like little things that
you can do it kind of like front-end
design design techniques and using color
kind of all the stuff that we've been
talking about and telling your story is
then turning that into a a journey so
that's the hero's journey the twelve
steps in the hero's journey so you don't
do things like say the world is really
terrible or you're into things we say
well when I was six years old I really
cared about the dolphins and that's why
you should care about the dolphins
because I care you don't want to make it
about yourself you want to make it all
doom and gloom you don't want to make it
or technical just like here's the data
blah blah blah you take people on a
journey so that starts with saying in
its there's 12 steps it starts with
having empathy that's what's called the
the ordinary world so I'll be like this
is what the world is like now and then
you have the call to adventure but the
world could be fantastic it could be
like this and then the third step is
refusal of the call where you and you
were like you're probably thinking that
I'm crazy but I'm not and then you
introduce yourself and the reason why
you can trust me is because I have these
qualifications or my organization and
then the next step that step four meet
the mentor and then Step five is cross
the threshold then he said will you come
with me you invite them come with me on
a journey and let me explain why and
then you go through the steps and then
you go into the inmost cave and the
ordeal and then we say okay this is why
it's going to be really great and
interesting this is why it's gonna be
really hard you're gonna have to give up
this that's gonna be tough and then you
go really deep and you go this is why it
matters the most X essentially
substantial reason for why it matters
not just because like trees matter so
you couldn't cut them down it forces you
to dig deeper so you'll say something
like you know your soul is connected
the planet you can't feel good about who
you are when you know a bad things are
happening you have to to be real with
who you are do something that is
connected to trees none of us can live
with ourselves and we know that bad
things are going on in the world so you
come up with something that's really
like strong that gets people like yeah
okay okay you got me you got me um and
then they come out of this then you have
like the happy ending you know and then
you basically okay we win the war we
defeat the enemy maybe the enemies
deforestation and this is the beautiful
happy ending this is this is the world
this is what we're all going for and the
hero's journey twelve steps will take
you through that so I've got to just a
nice little snapshot nice little
exercises of how you can get you use the
hero's journey for an tell a nonfiction
story even the most boring of nonfiction
stories can be made interesting with the
hero's journey nine tribes and tipping
points that's about marketing and social
influence basically that people copy
each other mm-hmm it's that simple
totally again don't worry about
educating people just got people to copy
each other it's called social diffusion
that's how everything happens in the
world and just being real with what you
what you want to make I mean what I mean
being real I just mean I would like
people to just make things that they
personally think are really awesome
because then other people will think
they're awesome too
I think people ask too much advice from
other people like oh do you like my
t-shirt design do you like my t-shirt
designs do you think you should do a
t-shirt design and then everybody's
asking everybody else do you like my
t-shirt and then everybody ends up the
same this is so interesting so there's
this example earlier in the book about
this guy Jesse Snell of Shell um who's a
wrote this game design textbook and he
said that he was he said that's exactly
what happens in juggling it's why it's
such a good example right
so in juggling everybody's looking how
to juggle like all the other jugglers
that's how you learn you look at other
jugglers but there's this one juggler
who does not refuses to learn to juggle
from other jugglers he goes to the
ballet he goes to look at swans right he
looks at machines and so he gets whole
new ideas and apparently this guy is
just totally different to all the other
jugglers he's got this amazing style
yeah and this guy Jesse the young Jesse
was just completely just wrapped with
this one other juggler and he says don't
Lee and his line is don't look at what
everyone else is doing look somewhere
else
yep yeah and I think that's just it's
like don't keep stop asking people what
they think all the time just do what you
you think is awesome yes far away your
inspiration is right it's like the
dancer that went out and started dancing
when no one else was dancing and then
first followers yeah yeah yeah and so
this is a very important point too is
that when you're when you're you're
right that when you have a new mental
map update the importance of the memes
spreading to get more people to copy
that update of the mental maps very
important but then also that creates a
culture of a homogeneous culture that
then we have to again divert out from
that homogeneous culture to look into
other places to see how we can update
the map to the next iteration so it's
this constant process of of iterating
and and I like that a lot I'm looking
especially when people talk about like
oh I don't well the one rule of the of
the chief executive officer that I'm
hiring for my new company is that they
have previously never worked at a
healthcare company it's like you don't
hire anyone for the CEO position that's
had 20 years of running a healthcare
company its hire someone from way
outside of the industry that is thinking
in novel ways about how to innovate on
the company so I'm glad that that you
brought that one up I mean it's just but
it's real everything that is in this
book I got from outside of the
environmental profession seriously every
single thing like there's I got it from
living in Silicon Valley in hacker
houses learning how to code that's how I
learned about sensors and satellite data
and all that i got it from studying
behavioral psychology you know books
like nudge and all the other related
behavioral psychology books um I got it
from studying about game
and learning about how games were built
and I got it from the self-help and from
the self-help industry like and so I
learned all this amazing stuff that was
just that now I bring to the
environmental world but I did not get it
from within sustainability you know it's
just the environmental engineering
ecology etc so I think everybody has to
jump outside of the silo and learn and
then that's how innovation happens
that's how new things new things happen
so I mean who wants everybody to just be
the same everyone looking at everyone to
be the same take the knowledge from
multiple disciplines and bring it in and
then be able to innovate that way and
this is a very powerful book and Katie
this is such a pleasure to be able to
talk to you about it and to unpack it
with you in this interview I want to ask
you a couple questions that we normally
ask on the way out of our show I'm glad
we talked a little bit about cybernetic
Earth and like kind of the future of
that technology I'm curious as to where
you kind of see a lot of the a lot of
the the artificial intelligence
technologies the blockchain technology
the sensor technologies the bio
technologies neuro technologies where do
you see this all leading to I'm not an
expert on all those things but where do
you see that with the fangs yes yes
within the cybernetic earth perspective
within the archaeological perspective
within the how to save the world
ideology I can't yeah yeah well I don't
know that much about the whole synthetic
biology and neuroscience developments so
I wouldn't have any thought about that
yet but the artificial intelligence
Nexus for the cybernetic earth is really
interesting because ultimately it's
being able to predict it's taking data
and doing predictions so there are
infinite examples of what you can do
with that obviously climate change take
the climate the earth climate data and
then predict what the climates going to
be what about surface temperature you
know it was like a fluid camera
can you look at the surface temperature
and then project for the next 24 or 48
hours you know for agriculture or for
fire what about air pollution how do you
predict and when I studied environmental
engineering which was 20 years started
twenty years ago now one of the main
things we learned was the calculus of
predicting pollution you know you've got
a pollution cloud and then you have to
do all this complicated calculus to
figure out well where all the pollution
cloud be in five days and how far will
it go right so predicting pollution
predicting impact temperature kilowatt
hours what about the relationship
between how many trees you have in your
city should a city spend another hundred
million dollars on tree projects how
will that affect the peak kilowatt hours
that the city is using during picked man
because trees call the city and how will
that affect the carbon dioxide emissions
what's your future projection based on
your previous data so you can feed all
the previous data into an AI model and
then predict well basically if we spend
a hundred million dollars on trees that
means we don't need to spend a hundred
million dollars on a new peak power
plant for when it gets really hot right
and if you can model that and you can
make a case to basically be like well
don't build the new gas Power Station
but the trees and instead so the city
doesn't get so hot so we don't need so
much air conditioning you could do that
with AI and that's what's really
exciting and it's only just started
people have only just started modeling
this type of stuff
using satellite doing image processing
of satellite images and then using that
data you can get a satellite image every
day now a lot and then looking into the
future and looking at how different
environmental metrics air pollution
temperature kilowatt hours rainfall
water flood how do they all affect each
other through the mathematical models
and how do we get better at predicting
that so that's something that's really
exciting interesting so it's actually
taking a lot of the heavy work of the
calculations and it's making the
our creative endeavoring more easy
because it's taking the workload of the
hard calculations off of us crunching so
many of the mathematical models with the
different variables to figure out what
is the best design of the systems that
maximize environmental sustainability
interesting I want to ask you cake the
three questions we asked on the way out
of the show first question is do you
think we're alone in the cosmos oh you
mean like aliens oh I I don't know I
don't know but I also don't think it
matters I mean we seem to be alone for
now based on the evidence but I mean so
what thank you we still have to make our
own worth earth work we still need to
have friends and fall in love and eat
food and not get depressed and have
meaningful lives and eat and raise
children I mean we've got all very
important things I think to do do you
think that we come from somewhere
outside of the three-dimensional reality
into these earth suits I a little bit
yeah I actually have a double-page
spread that's really lovely in my in my
book about the the universe the
beginning of time of the universe energy
blob this big you actually get a photo
of it on Wikipedia the energy blob when
the universe was nine years old I think
it was nine years old maybe it was nine
million baby universe and then out of
the blob of energy they weren't even
atoms there wasn't even gravity like
they were and then the laws of the
universe started to happen and then
atoms formed then atoms stuck together
into bigger molecules and then into
planets and then life so if you look at
that like there's this creative energy
if you think look at that energy blob
that energy blob wanted to create it
created atoms and it's trying to create
and it made itself from a blob into what
it is now and we're kind of part of that
so if you want to say that that's like
an earth suit with that energy kind of
going through us yeah that's what I I
mean I don't use the word earth suit
but I think that you wear a continuum of
that creative process that's a kind of
life's work and that that's why we're
here we're here to continue the creative
evolution of the universe yes and do you
believe we're in a simulation no no I
sorry am I meant to say yes because
that's the no no absolutely not we were
we welcome all different perspectives on
on the show on that question up so we
always welcome all different
perspectives period on the show so yeah
so what are your thoughts are we in a
simulation uh no but I don't I know that
some people think that but it's not
really my scene okay I'm more in the
practical like let's just like get a
tree planted by the end of the day kind
of a kind of same and the last question
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world most
beautiful in the world
oh right now my three-year-old girl is
starting to look like a miniature movie
star I mean she's just objectively very
very cute not even my mother's opinion
she just is fact you can meet her you'll
agree and I get to wake up with it every
morning she's just like this in my arms
and I get to see this beautiful being so
it's really wonderful there's a lot of
craziness that comes with molding a mind
into the world so we wish you the best
of luck
Anastasia the result yeah well mice for
so before in two weeks yeah I mean it's
coming
the it's cool that it's cool I love what
you were teaching me earlier about how
the mind being like origami it's kind of
like you know Anastasia is exploring her
you know fullest potential now in the
world and how what's gonna be her little
puzzle piece that she fits into the
great 8 billion
human story yes she is the piece of
origami that is unfolding and I just
gotta kind of like hang back just do dis
prevention basically make sure she's
okay and then yeah nutrients death
prevention most important things and uh
and in the origami just kind of unfolds
on its own it's really fascinating to
watch yeah yeah this has been such a
pleasure Katie thank you so much for
coming on to our show having me yeah I
really appreciate it and we would love
for everyone to check out the links
below to Katie's work check out Katie
Patrick comm check out the new book how
to save the world really help you a lot
with your execution and we hope to see
all of your ideas come to fruition so
check us out go follow Katie on Twitter
as well her links below and we would
love for you to comment on your thoughts
on the episode so give us your thoughts
in the comments below also go and share
the content with other people about how
to save the world some of these idea
execution strategies go and share share
them with your family your community
your friends online on the internet go
and share them around support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in simulations links are below
support us help us grow help us prosper
as well and support the artists in your
communities help them grow and go and
build the future everyone manifests your
dreams into the world
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace